i'm gonna be in l.a with jay
i'm in love and just like that miranda's
moving to la with che
well temporarily moving to la with che i
know
so shocking is shocking it's shocking
during the season one finale of the sex
and the city revival series and just
like that che gives miranda a whole song
and dance about how they are picking up
and moving across the country
well east coast girls
[Music]
no literally che delivers a surprise
with a song and dance
all of this
is my humble way of sharing with you
my near and dear
that uh
yours truly is going to california
[Applause]
hollywood cold [ __ ]
and that's when che hits miranda with
this i want you to come to la
i'm sorry i didn't have time to do a
whole song about it
you want me to come to l.a of course i
want you to come
there's definitely a lot to take in
between these two and the possibilities
are endless i think that these two
characters might inspire each other to
um i don't know show up in a way that
could develop something really really
exciting and electric
yeah while chase offer is totally
exciting and super electric there's a
catch miranda has to give up a coveted
work opportunity to go what about that
internship at human rights watch
i i i guess i'm gonna have to pull out
you know
for now
are you sure about that
it's really competitive internship i'm
following my heart here and trying not
to second-guess myself the way i usually
would
and all that echoes what cynthia nixon
told et about bringing the show back
nearly two decades after the original
series wrapped we came back to
to throw these characters into new
situations and let them
you know follow their hearts you didn't
like us because we were boring the first
time you liked us because we took
chances and that's what we're doing so
how did the girls take the news
why can't i choose love over an
internship
well you can of course you can
but
what are you gonna do in la all day sit
in an audience and laugh
maybe
is anyone else getting major season six
sex in the city vibes you know when
miranda judges carrie for quitting her
column to move to paris with alexander
petrovsky this is the time when
everybody should be really excited for
me we just want to make sure you think
this through
anyway back to miranda am i not allowed
to change a little bit
or a lot
or change back again if i feel like it
do i have to follow my own rigid rules
until the day that i die we're 55 you
know it's a moment in
in women's lives where they often do
kind of reevaluate where they are
there's more
behind me than there is left but i'm
still plenty young enough that i could
actually embark on a whole new adventure
so will fans get a season two to see how
it all plays out in la who knows what's
gonna happen here's what cynthia and
mario cantone aka anthony told e.t i am
not a writer and so that is one of the
great privileges of not being a writer
is it's not my job to figure it out
thought you know thank god they know
much better than i oh i don't know what
the
thing they don't tell me anything why is
that because
i got a big mouth
[Laughter]
are you hoping for a season two of
course i am i'm very hoping for a season
two but you know
when it's announced you'll have me back
and we'll drink and
dance
[Music]
you